on a donné les clés de la banque de sang
au vampire l'image est peut-être forte
mais la part des agences de placement de
personnel explosent depuis cinq ans dans
le réseau de la santé en 2016-2017 le
réseau a payé 170 millions pour
embaucher des travailleurs d'agences
privées une somme qui est passée à 918
millions en 2021 2022 ça représente
maintenant 5% de la masse salariale il
faut se justement se libérer de cette
dépendance aux agences et pour ça il
faut un plan d'investissement dans le
secteur public dans les conditions de
travail des conditions de travail
déficience qui alimentent cette fuite
vers les agences elles offrent une plus
grande flexibilité des horaires est
souvent un meilleur salaire des hôpitaux
ou perdent ainsi des employés qu'ils
doivent réembaucher à Fort prix aux
agences privées Québec veut briser ce
cercle vicieux avec un projet de loi qui
sera déposé mercredi
plus besoin d'un changement de culture
dans le réseau et le changement de
culture pour moi va passer par ce mode
de gestion là qu'on avait d'utiliser des
gens d'externes nos entreprises ne
volent pas de personnel au réseau de la
santé le secteur estime que éliminer les
agences éloignera encore plus de travail
du réseau de la santé de penser que de
façon utopique on va contraindre ces
gens-là intégrer le réseau de la santé
par la force via un projet de loi qui
viendrait
bloquer les agences de placement qui
viendraient enrayer les agences de
placement ça tient de la pensée topique
et les infirmières ne sont plus la seule
dans les rares les deux tiers des
montants versés par les établissements
publics aux agences de placement privés
l'ont été pour l'embauche d'autres
professionnels comme par exemple des
travailleurs sociaux ou encore des
ergothérapeutes ici David Gentile
Radio-Canada Montréal